Aaron is with us in Pennsylvania Aaron
how are you I'm good thanks how are you
better than I deserve what's up so I
just graduated for my master's program
recently and I was really lucky not to
take out any loans for it
right and doing this yeah and during
this time since I was 17
I did a lot of freelance work which I've
saved up a lot in savings just over
$300,000 and yeah to $2,000 so from 17 -
how old are you now I'm 25 from 17 to 25
in the last seven years while you were
getting your undergrad in your masters
room put three hundred thousand dollars
in the bank yeah I went to colleges that
I didn't pay tuition for and I applied
for lots of grants and scholarships to
help pay for my living expenses
ding-dang and I stayed with my parents
nice job all the time
so what's your master Sam I'm a
classical musician so I got it in island
performance Wow good for you and 100%
100% free with it and so what was your
freelance you said you were doing
freelance are you playing the violin
yeah I was playing that violin I was
chewing around but I was quite limited
sometimes I would teach as well when I
was younger especially the younger
students and I still teach today as well
now so what did you make touring I'm
curious
touring it's really unstable so mmm like
two years ago I made about 50,000 in one
year and then last year was really good
was just under a hundred thousand but
this year is less it's 60,000 so it's
really fluctuating I understand okay
not a bad side gig while you're going
through college yeah I was really lucky
no there's no now you keep saying that
there's no luck involved here you've
worked your butt off you've been very
diligent you've been very careful you
lived at home and you are obviously a
world-class musician well 24 year olds
don't make fifty to a hundred grand
unless they're really good okay so yeah
I know this I mean it's not it's not I
don't I don't have to know anything
about music to figure that part out so
what did you make when you were tutoring
other younger kids
much did you charge when I was in my
seventeen I charged fifty an hour but
fifty may charge 100 yes
fifty dollars an hour love you you're
awesome this is a story so you are so
successful how can I help you so my
question is my parents were never
trained with money they just only told
me to always save and keep my costs low
mm-hmm but I've been listening to your
show a lot and I realized that I have a
lot of a better situation than most
people to have a lot of savings and I
haven't really invested it except for
three years worth of Roth IRA how should
I go amongst building wealth at this
stage should I like sure you say put it
in like uh like an index fund sometimes
just but should I put it all at once or
how should I best organize this okay
first thing what you do is to contact
one of our smart investor pros and begin
to get one of them in your corner and
just click smart investor at Dave Ramsey
calm and sit down with them now what
you're looking for is someone who you
connect with who has the heart of a
teacher because their job is not to do
your investing their job is to show you
some options on investing and teach you
how they work and they'll make you some
really good suggestions in this
situation but you're going to learn from
them so that you and you don't you don't
depend on them you don't depend on me
you depend on your brain and growing
your knowledge in these areas so that
you can start doing some investing and
yeah I'm probably going to send some of
this towards some mutual funds and I'm
gonna be thinking about when you're
gonna buy a house someday and I'm gonna
use some of it for that I might even pay
cash for a house oh my goodness you're
in such a good position when you're
ready to buy I mean you're gonna be in a
an amazing position to do that
and so what does your future career look
like well over the next say five years
what are your plans and what do you
think you'll make yeah I'm hoping to
keep it more stable at least around I'm
guessing around 70,000 is the median
with
the highs and lows for the next five
years I was thinking about buying a
place but then also I'm never there and
my parents are very open with me staying
with them when I need to and I'm hardly
at home anyways so I've been just taking
that option for now because I don't know
where I want to be based anyways yeah I
think you can decide when you're gonna
put down roots a little bit before you
buy that'll be fine you've done very
well sir congratulations you've set
yourself up and you're obviously a very
talented young man congratulations